that we start with covid vaccinations
expected to be made compulsory for
people in germany from february the
german chancellor angela merkel has
described the situation in germany as
very serious saying covert cases are far
too high let's bring in our europe
correspondent adam parsons and well this
is going to cause some controversy adam
yeah it will cause considerable
controversy
it's not a hundred percent guaranteed we
should say that
because this is not something that can
just be brought in
certainly not by angela merkel who's
just about to leave office nor indeed by
olaf schultz the man who is
99.99 recurring percent likely to
succeed her
as chancellor it will require a vote in
the german parliament the bundestag it
will be an open vote so
parliamentarians will vote on their
conscience but mr schultz says that he
expects it to pass and all polls suggest
that actually germans are in favor of
this it's a big change of direction
though because up until recently mrs
merkel said that she wanted the onus to
be on persuading germans to get
vaccinated in sufficient quantities but
so far that vaccination rate in germany
is about 67.5
it's just not seen as being anywhere
near high enough and so this vaccine
mandate is likely to come into effect uh
as soon as february it will be
enormously controversial uh austria
neighboring austria has already said it
will do the same thing bringing in a
mandate
on the first of february but
interestingly germany hasn't stopped
there it is also bringing in what has
been referred to as the lockdown of the
unvaccinated
which will effectively create two tiers
of citizenship i don't really see
any other way of putting it because if
you are not vaccinated you will not be
allowed to go to non-essential shops and
you will not be allowed to go
to uh
leisure activities effectively you will
be curtailed
in your movements now germany will not
be alone in that you look at
another country italy for instance
obliges people to either be tested or
recovered or vaccinated if they are to
go
into their workplace but actually to
make this this differential between
vaccinated and unvaccinated
is a big step for
the european union's biggest wealthiest
probably most influential country this
happens at a moment when olive schulte
is taking over noticeably i think
another german ursula von der line the
president of the european commission
just yesterday said that the eu needed
to start having a conversation about
mandatory vaccinations i suspect she had
an eye on what was going on
in her home country and it will be
without any doubt uh controversial uh as
i said there are there is a majority in
favor of these kind of enhanced actions
in germany but we know that in germany
as in so many other countries
there is a sizable minority of people
who have not been vaccinated not because
of health not because of youth but
because they do not want to be
vaccinated and have resisted every siren
call to change their mind and those
people are already complaining
vociferously that they have been
stigmatized that they have been cut out
of society and that it is frankly unfair
to have one set of rules for the
vaccinated once for the unvaccinated and
i wonder whether it will only be the
unvaccinated who compare or whether
there will be others people who have had
the vaccine people who sign up to
vaccine programs but are still troubled
by this
state
idea of there being effectively a
two-tier society angela merkel wouldn't
have wanted this on the last day olive
schultz wouldn't have wanted this as his
first bit of statement policy but
germany has seen cases rising steeply
recently country that did so well got so
many plaudits for its actions in the
first wave of this pandemic is now
struggling particularly in the east of
the country knew that it had to do
something big
but this
big thing
is going to be very very controversial